كيف لاكبري ناقلا للانترنت ان اي يحارب
باقوى اسلحته القوه الناعمه ومن الصعوبه
بل المستحيل ان يتنازل اراعي الثوره
التكنولوجيه عن عرش العالمي الانترنت كما
نعرفه اليوم وهو جوجل جوجل ستور واندرويد
لشركه الفابات فيسبوك وانستغرام وواتساب
تويتر سناب شات وبطبع مايكروسوفت هذا هو
الانترنت امريكي
ان يكون الاكثر شعبيه عالميا ولا المفارقه
اصبح امرا واقعا وفي وقتا فاصف الازمات
بالسلك مالي عاصمه الابتكار التي شكلت
ورسمت عالم اليوم منذ ثلاثه عقود
وسناخذكم بالمناسبه في رحله في غدا اذا
وفي بكين المقابل سيليكون فالي اخر في
اصبح مركزه جدبان ل 20,000 كيانا
التكنولوجي ولكن باي حجم نتحدث عن ايرادات
تصلوا الى 800 مليار دولار سنويا ومن
الواحه الصينيه برز كابوس الامن الامريكي
نحن في 2019 في واشنطن البنتاجون يطلب من
افراد الجيش
وبعدها بسبعه اشهر يوليو 2020 تنتقلوا
عدوى الخوف الى شركه امازون ثم ثم الى
المكتب البيضاوي في البيت الابيض اغسطس
الفين وعشرين اجتماعا شهد حديده احتدام
بحضور الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب بين
بيتر نيبارو المستشار التجاري في البيت
الابيض و ستيفن نيوتن ووزير الخزانه
وعنوان الخلاف كيف سنتعامل مع تيك توك
فكره توم اندشن كانت اجبار دانس الصينيه
على بيع تيك توك
يا بقره اعتبر ذلك تساهل مع بكين اتفق
ترامب مع نافارو وايضا مع النوتشين في
السادس من اغسطس الرئيس الامريكي يوقع
امرا تنفيذيا بحضرتك
45 يوما في حال لم تقبل الشركه الصينيه
بيضا
تطبيقها للولايات المتحده